Now, the movement is king. He wants a pass from me. I'll let
him go. I'm being pulled out by Kunigami Barrow's rush. It's because many of them are
geniuses that I'm
aiming for. Take it. It's
pretending to be a dribbling to get the octopus out, but in reality, it's
Nagye's warning.  Do you want me to make a motion to scatter and create a pass course?
[Music]
Damn, did I invite you? It's a
flying honey trap. I want to fly well.
You who stopped are helpless. Break up with me and do something.
Everyone over there concentrates on my play.
You've been waiting for this split second to cut through the darkness in the space that only I can see.You watched it
right.No matter
how hard you knock on someone's heart, you
can't change them.That's why...  You have no choice but to
change. There's
probably no other way to change a world that doesn't go the way you want.
If you can't see the light towards your goal, you
can become that light.
This
applies to you. The darkness in the field you've created is
He eats me and
turns me into a gal. He
used me for his own goals.